it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kid
we're out come on baby
i want to start the show by saying that
i heard a piece of gossip and it it is
as big as remember when i broke the news
that that bruce jenner was going to be
caitlyn jenner
and and this is i think this is bigger
or i think it's actually bigger oh for
sure but there's nothing i can say
it's not honest it's not honest without
somebody and we don't know them take it
easy dude i'm not saying you've already
said too much i'm not saying who it is
you've already said too much let me
thought i'm shh i'm not the we i'm not
even that club yeah i know but be quiet
anyway i just like to start things by
saying there are there's information
that i have anybody that nobody out
there
yeah
is going to know tell me but you will
eventually i don't know i don't think so
i believe i don't think so you'd ever
come out you're you couldn't be more
wrong i believe in life maybe there is
no way maybe when they're like 80 maybe
but in and here's the thing
when you as a human being are holding on
to a secret
when you as a human being are not living
authentic your your authentic self that
[ __ ] will [ __ ] it will find its way
i don't know it's tough can you imagine
having to live that way
it's tough
good actor
hey
i'm not saying he's an actor guys i'm
scratched that part you know he can't
help himself you'd have to be an actor
though okay like even if you're not in
the actual professional yeah yeah you'd
still but just you're acting in life
your entire life is an act that's what i
mean that's what i'm saying like you
like your entire life
your entire life is an act yes that's
what i'm saying like yeah and i
yeah
you know but i've always picked up on
that
with that yeah i always picked up on it
the very first time you met me you did
the first time i met mark
harley it's dicey dicey
um what's going on not much brother i
shot three episodes of ridiculousness 10
total most reoccurring guests of all
time
yeah rob dierdick is one of the not only
smartest people and the coolest people
i've met but he's also [ __ ] um
like is there anybody more dialed in who
plans who plans his life to the nth
degree
well on on the fight companion when he
goes i've had exactly three bad days in
2020 i was like what the [ __ ] chris goes
i've had all bags i've had all the bad
days
i'm with some of these people does
anyone actually watch this show anymore
people still watch cable television so
just so you morons know he is that show
is
the views on that there's a reason why
they i won't release how much he gets
paid there's a reason why he is the
entire network
he's the entire network what happened
with mtv they were so big i did one of
the last shows
called death valley which was one of the
greatest shows ever [ __ ] done and
made where we were all hunting [ __ ]
uh bad guys we were hunting bad guys we
it was we were in the valley of los
angeles right there i was the chief and
we hunted vampires werewolves and um
uh vampires werewolves and zombies did
anybody go on to do anything after that
or uh
nobody looks familiar there katie lots
is on arrow with on arrow forever
that beautiful blonde who's one of my
favorite people on the planet i love her
so much that was her kind of breakout
thing she never stopped working after
that texas battle is one of the greatest
guys he's a soap guy
uh tanya ramon ramond is was on a show
for a while and she's
she's like one of those intellectuals
and she looks like that she's gorgeous
charlie was a
groundling so he's always popping up on
stuff and bryce johnson i haven't seen
him much but he just did something i
think so they're all working but they
yeah i mean that's a success in itself
to stay current and working exactly mtv
there but that show was so good and what
they did was they kept breaking up with
commercials so they wouldn't even let it
you'd see one minute of it and they
break it up with four minutes of
commercials it killed the show yeah i
mean nothing well imagine how much of a
success it'd be today if it's on like
netflix or paramount or forget it hbo
but it's as far as like network tv even
mtv like they're
you know they make their not off 16 and
pregnant teen mom and then the big one
is ridiculousness yeah that's what they
do and then wild and out was really big
for them but they kind of
and also for the younger generation
remember when i was growing up mtv was
huge for music they don't do music at
all anymore not at all at all nothing
they don't touch music trl was massive
the top ten was eminem britney spears
backstreet boys yeah that's tanya ramon
by the way beautiful and brilliant and
brilliant god she's gorgeous that's cool
and brilliant well she's an alien she'd
be reading like tomas man she'd be
reading she speaks like three different
languages she'd be reading in that
language
she's like she looks like that but she
comes from like a super intellectual
like she seems cool yeah she's actually
awesome but also mtv was saying like
now with the younger audience like you
know the people that watch game of
thrones and like narcos and stuff aren't
teeny boppers you know like the the
attention span it's all tick-tock like
they have to figure out like how to grab
the attention of kids and it's such a
short time to do it so they're trying to
figure that algorithm movies are dealing
with this
movies are dealing with the fact that
all of our brains have been rewired
because cell phones
well with tick-tock that's what i'm
saying cell phones yeah yeah tick-tock
even youtube like
you have you know you have a full like
say fight campaign for instance you have
a full long three-hour episode bro
i mean
people our age are watching three hours
but then most of them are just watching
the clips the clips will get more views
in the full episode
yeah it's just the way it goes look at
specials
okay now meet with anybody you want to
everyone will tell you looking at the
actual analytics everyone doesn't matter
who you are stop watching the majority
after 28 minutes that's right
that's right after 20 back in the day it
was full no i don't know anybody stopped
watching after an hour i mean that's
just like your favorite comic but in
general the the public stops watching
after 28 minutes mm-hmm
that's the attendance man so it's kind
of a bummer it's beyonce was complaining
about that she's like nobody wants to
hear a body of work anymore they want to
hear one song oh no yeah but you know
the reason why like drake and
certain guy like kanye were they really
so many songs because in order it's
something in the algorithm spotify and
the billboard there has to be a certain
amount of songs to reach that level so
if you only release you know whatever
four tracks you're not going to be
featured on that stuff so they do it
they know it's not the greatest body of
work but they know three songs in there
will be [ __ ] bangers and that's why
they do so wait wait so they'll release
like one feature two feature whole three
features whole album okay but the whole
album like 20 songs i don't want to
listen to 20 even i don't listen yes
from my favorite artists there's no way
it's 20 hits right but they're doing it
because it gets them in that it they
they're allowed access to that you know
to get the tracking that they have to to
meet the requirements to whatever get
the platinum or whatever that bolt
everything has changed so much
in five years think about how much this
[ __ ] is nuts right now the question is
what what is the business and what are
we going to be doing in 10 years what's
it look like
i don't i mean i don't know how much
longevity there's then with this because
there's also comics out there who
they'll do one clip that
whatever goes viral and people [ __ ] with
and gets let's say
10 million views and it's a minute 20
and they're selling out theaters
but if it's just a minute 20 i don't
give a [ __ ] what act you are in the
theater it has to be an hour after an
hour okay so that 120. it gets quiet
right quick after that minute 20. so
there are people that have had
sold 10 years worth of tickets off of
one viral video
you know but if it's 10 years that means
that means they're doing a good show
because that if you just do a let's say
you have a clip that goes super viral
it's a minute 30 and you're you're
riding that wave for a year well yeah
you're flashing the pin if you're known
for seven years ten years you're doing
something right that means people are
coming back 100 percent
100 percent
that girl and hello is johnson she did
that with that one clip that's right the
nail salon yeah
she never stopped
she was ready to go though yeah you know
what i'm saying like it's true i've
never seen her in person she's so pretty
though yeah yeah i never beast yeah
critical jail yeah she's somebody who
had she remember she was on mad tv so
she was already talented she was already
experienced she was already working her
ass off
you know i hear good things about her
and i think she's she's latin right yeah
but a lot of people thought she was
asian because of the crypto gel like
obviously that's an asian thing
yeah she's she's a former nfl
cheerleader
cast member of mad tv season 13. damn
every good for her
yeah crushing it
hey b let's take a little break yeah uh
and if you need a break i will be in
appleton wisconsin
september 10th through the 12th come get
some appleton wisconsin's i'm sorry
that's september 8th through the 10th
appleton wisconsin i'm an ontario improv
september 15th through 17th i close
september with the trash panda tour
september 29th through october 1st is
laugh boston get you some tickets at
thickboy.com b give me your dates see
some raleigh north carolina's good
nights i'll be uh there september 8th
and 9th and 10th good nights in raleigh
north carolina san jose california
improv september 15 16 17. speaking of
washington spokane comedy club september
22 24. i'm a busy boy in september
check out best of don't forget but
listen man when i'm doing a show like
best of when i'm out on the road i need
nutrition i need energy dude you still
taking that multivitamin i'm taking that
multi-bite bro what if i could drink a
multivitamin dude how about ag-1 by
athletic greens listen it is a super
food product it brings comprehensive and
convenient daily nutrition to everybody
not just you brian keeping up with
research knowing what to do taking a
bunch of pills and capsules it's hard on
the stomach
sometimes you have to eat you feel sick
dude not with ag-1 one tasty scoop of
ag-1 contains 75 vitamins minerals whole
food sourced ingredients including a
multi-vitamin brian okay dude we got
your bro mineral probiotic green
superfood blend how about that's my
favorite eight ounce of water i doubt it
i feel fantastic join the movement
athletes life flights moms dads rookies
aunts gail contains one
less less than a gram of added sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals no or artificial
anything and it tastes good oh it's
fantastic and they'll give you by the
way one free year of vitamin d a supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
fighter
athleticgreens.com
again all you gotta do is go to athletic
greens.com fighter take control of your
health and give aj one a try let's get
back to the program
yeah man what else what else has uh what
you've been doing so you did really
ridiculousness three episodes yep here's
that such down to science man it's nuts
no crap they just remember during the
pandemic they couldn't they still shot
through the pandemic but couldn't have a
live audience so i figured oh things are
normal now we have live audience no he's
like i like we like you better without
it's faster you don't you can you know
knock out more shows without live
audience there's no more live audience
just the staff in there wow just rob the
staff you know uh steelo brim and chanel
west coast and they knock out [ __ ]
eight episodes a day
like he has it down to a [ __ ] pure
science dude my daughter uh started high
school
and i won't say the high school but um
freshman freshman and
her first day she's super excited you
know
and uh well there was a fight among two
freshman boys
and uh one got stabbed what the yeah the
kid pulled out a knife
and cut the other kid up now the
encouraging thing is that the police
were there in exactly
30 seconds they don't [ __ ] around in
schools anymore but
and i said well can we get some metal
detectors here's the problem with a big
public school
you would take you you can't have that
because it would take take forever to
get it would take forever yeah kids were
like oh i'm sorry
i had my you know dick piercing and yeah
i take it out like it's going to take
forever yeah
i don't know how many kids have dick
piercings like you know what i'm saying
like you're hiding some metal some metal
is in there yeah so it means they oh my
pager i don't know it's gonna be a
thousand things oh my nintendo gloves
yep all that stuff so i was like oh
there are no metal details that's
realistic interesting not realistic so i
guess we gotta just roll the old dice
now i got a kid in high school and
that's what i think about that's
freshmen
i go my daughter i go freshman i go what
happened he goes got stabbed i said what
do you mean he goes got caught up in the
face got stabbed in the body i went well
that's a huge issue but she was it's her
like they're used to like mass shootings
she's like man whatever well that's what
i mean because of at first i said it was
a fight and i was it was a fight and the
cops were there immediately and then
security and there was all these fire
departments and i was like for a fist
fight what the [ __ ] has happened to our
country what's going on these [ __ ] my
daughter goes he got stabbed dad
i go
18 year olds he goes no no the kid was
they were freshmen kid got stabbed dude
imagine
i can't
first hey
well you know you're not going back to
school like first day of school first
day of school who's like you know i'm
gonna bring this knife just in case that
larry kid pops off i mean why that's not
a good way to start and also back when i
was in high school in whatever 1999
you didn't shank each other but if
someone did shank someone that's
that's the story for the year that's
right for my entire high school national
news ladies and gentlemen oh that's a
big deal now i remember anything about
it i didn't make the news
it sure didn't it sure didn't
that's not
yeah there's some weird [ __ ] that goes
on
i this is a this is a weird story but
mine was your first day of high school
my daughter's had some weird [ __ ] like
in her middle school
a father was having a custody of dispute
with his
wife and her and he went
to the [ __ ]
front of the school and shot himself
just like oh yeah here you go boom
like some people are just like it's like
that thing where i can't kill you i'm
gonna kill myself yeah yeah no doubt hey
did you did your daughter go to the
school uh in the movie dangerously she
goes to the school michelle's
her [ __ ] her michelle pfeiffer came
out and got rid of the body and it that
she's in that school that's nice
the dad was just like oh yeah you want
to play this game yeah and it was during
school hours
yeah wow they say my son in your face
my son my son now who's uh 11
were in great
he's in fifth i told you the story where
where i'm in bora bora
and he goes he goes you know
dad
so you know how like when you do
something nice to somebody you get a
warm fuzzy feeling and they say that
your temperature your body temperature
changes i've never heard that i'm like
yeah sure okay sure
he goes so so i did this experiment it
was really cool the water was kind of
cold
and then i ordered a coke
and i tipped the waiter
forty dollars okay
and i got back in the water and the
water was warmer okay let it go
uh and by the way he's so [ __ ] sneaky
that i know he he knew he probably
[ __ ] up i go you gave him 40 and my
son goes
yeah but it was a really cool experiment
i go i know but you tipped him 40 bucks
and it's not on you to sign for [ __ ]
first of all yeah because i don't know
where you learned how you could sign for
[ __ ] and don't tip forty dollars and he
said he goes i know dad but he's a
waiter
smart
smart he can't be mad at him smart i was
like you little [ __ ] experiment i
know i shouldn't give him 40 what's an
experiment pops just an experiment
four that guy was crunk just off one
coke the guy was probably like he should
have been like but you're 11 kid you're
just not real i know but he's like
probably he's instead he's like some
rich kid bora bora yeah hell yeah forty
dollars tahitian but also hey uh
just piss in the water you want to warm
up dude take one from your uncle be here
just piss in the water
you want a warm sensation all around you
piss hard in that water also that
water's not cold though right no yeah
here's what i did
um so it's french polynesia tahiti
tahiti is french polynesia the french
came in like 1962 colonized the [ __ ] out
of them enslaved them and did their
thing that's what they did back in the
day what they did
now the tahitians were way bigger than
the average frenchman yeah they're thick
but
they're bigger than you yeah they're
samoan basically numbers
no it's a technology game the french
were like that's cool we have gun powder
and muskets
and we're going to shoot you yeah that's
all that advancement and technology all
that stuff yeah so but good old bride
now they speak french
everybody speaks french because it's
french polynesia now b speaks in french
so b is popping off from french
thing is the tahitians don't like
speaking french oh
yeah
that's question she didn't know that he
didn't i'm showing off and they're
asking me in english because they hate
it yeah yeah they probably dread it yeah
that yeah
the language that of the college yeah
that enslaved them yeah i'm speaking the
language of the congress in my best
french accent and i can't figure out why
they're not responding
uh i told you i had the best massage in
my life there though right no
oh
i get in there and i i look at a
tahitian woman now
i'm you know i'm not a very sturdy guy
i'm i'm a thin thin i'm a ranger kid
then
and the uh there's my nephew stud that's
kid who was kicking the 68 yard field
goal
yeah he's [ __ ] jacked and that's my
son with my bone structure
it's great oh that's your son-in-law
yeah jesus christ looks like you that's
fighting the kid that's patterning
fighting the kid how did you not need to
put fire in the kid that's the kid circa
2022. i should have yeah that's that's
spider in the kid that's the new fighter
finally kid in when we're in high school
by the way that's exactly right yes
that's classic
[Music]
what'd they say
that's so [ __ ] dallas
dallas
tristan
um but but it was so funny because i
[ __ ] uh i get there and uh i go to
the massage place and i need a good
massage i've been playing volleyball
tennis i like lifting weights yeah bro
and l.a it's stressful because you don't
know if you yanked off or yeah you know
it's horrible not it's not the four
state seasons in bora bora this is a
classy joint
and
a tahitian woman walks in now again
there are sturdy people she's shorter
than i am but every bit is every bit way
stronger yeah way stronger you put her
on a leg machine thick ankles the cash
bench machine you're putting all your
money on her you know when you go to
massage parties we want the opposite of
deshawn watson thank you you want an
actual massage thank you yes she's got
feet hands forearms she's just a big boy
nope
uh her name is tahani very pretty but
just i'm way too light in the ass for a
teaching woman way too light in the ass
um
and i said i made the mistake of saying
i would like it to be deep tissue deep
all she did was smile and motion to the
table i was in the same [ __ ] room as
my my girl
i hate that yeah doubles massage yeah
well my girl i heard it because i think
i was doing this i was going oh well
they said it's a it's a view of the
ocean you're not looking at the ocean
but i know face down yeah yeah ass up
face down correct
so she started working on me and i was
going
and my girl was like hey
you have to stop this you have to you're
ruining it it's painful shut the [ __ ] up
she was getting in there getting in
there like she got she got into my cabs
with the elbow oh big moana elbow and
then she was just her thumbs alone i
came out of there i was so i was flat as
a [ __ ] pancake
flat as a pancake did it help though
no no i was sore for three a runny nose
sometimes when it started because your
face is down yeah and your your nose
toxins all the toxins you're leaving
your body they push everything towards
you
yeah i wasn't the same three days she
goes you're gonna be sore tomorrow yeah
three days yeah she got a little too
deep
especially in the valley it's nice you
can't pull up this place that says asian
massage no no no
no i tried to get one the other day and
i went in and it was like there's bars
oh my god this isn't i just walked down
like this
i've been i've gone to one of those my
friends sent me to one and i wanted a
massage i didn't want to yank and i
walked in and i went well i was to all
these asian women and i was like
everybody here is in some one way or
another an indentured servant or a slave
nobody wants to do that nobody wants
this nobody wants to be massaging some
[ __ ]
white dude you don't know in his 40s
that's disgusting i got the [ __ ] out of
there well i i didn't know this place
looked official and then i got in and
they said oh 40 like 40 cash i'm like
cat i'm like oh well
i'm here let's see what happens yeah but
you know it's [ __ ] when they just
start making [ __ ] up like they're like
walking on your back or they're just
like
trying to you know like [ __ ] you this
[ __ ] idiot wants a real massage yeah
and they gotta figure it out do you have
any tip money like can we just jack you
off and get out of here i'm like no no
no let's go and get those hammies to get
the feet yeah it's like a it's like a
shitty massage the worst the worst now
let me ask you this question do you
think
if you had a massage parlor
with
stud dudes stud dudes
great as the masseuse as the mooses
and women women from all over
knew
that they could go there safe place
anonymously
and have sex oh with the best looking
guy i don't know what i was thinking
would they would that place make money
absolutely sir you think so i think so
now you're gonna have about a six month
run for get shut down by the fed let's
just say it was underground let's say it
was on some island it was i just pitched
cat the other day she has the money now
and i'm hoping she's in on it you know
i'll put up half the money you know the
the coffee
the coffee and strippers
the asian coffee places she talks about
yeah remember that idea yes in newport
that that goes on that dark roast yeah
dark roast
i think there's so many issues with that
regulations and devices
yeah it's human sex trafficking brian
there's so many red flags listen but
it's like that like that's green tea or
is it pissed that's green tea yeah
that's what i'm looking not that that's
too what would you call what would you
call your coffee place tits tits oh no
and a jolt no no no that's two on the
nose yeah you know
um
latte it would be more like that it
would be maybe classy it'd be classy
latte and ladies now these girls you got
to have your head on a swivel because
they are serving up hot beverages so you
can't just be willy-nilly about it we
can't be spilling in a triple shot
espresso on the customers they're very
cute yeah let's see right that's even
see that's too much we don't want
lingerie we don't want it no no pasties
like the one in the middle we don't want
to give our hand away here you're
thinking you're coming for a nice dark
roast maybe we have some french press
could take a little time now while that
french pro french press is just the
aroma and the one on the right she's my
number one pick so as as the beans are
flourishing you're chatting you're
chatting maybe maybe they you have an
expert barista and a roaster who's doing
all that stuff yeah oh yeah three of
them i mean we're packed to the gills no
food just coffee i can see the ads for
that it'd be pretty cool you just have
girls just in just drinking coffee in
bikinis that's it
the but the bad that's a good let me see
that bring that back that now no to the
right and we give we have fair wages all
right and you can keep all tests i'm
very happy with all those gals yep yep
second one in from the right is going to
be serving up just um iced coffee okay
yeah well because it gets too hot
otherwise but we don't do that [ __ ]
there's no croissants there's no no
there's no cake pops no strictly java
baby it's just java we don't do any uh
[ __ ] pumpkin spice lattes dude we're
just java and tits and they're and
they're just in bikinis yep then you
can't put any almond milk in it lingerie
and bikini no sweeteners
now if you want the lingerie you know
you're talking about that dark roast
boom boom room okay okay okay so that
might be if you if you want that okay
you walk in and that's what's going on
no no no no that's behind the curtain
okay so you want to run out now you're
talking about being a vip client okay
okay you're talking about you're talking
about if you got the money
things can turn brothel right quick
yeah you said it i didn't my business
i'm just saying now now you're a
frequent flyer are you frequent java
flyer because in order to get into that
boom boom java room yeah you need 10
stamps
we just don't you got to earn it got it
we don't know if your hot head can't
come back dude we have straight security
vietnamese security you're looking at
them it's mark okay
you would you serve market vietnamese
coffee sweet and condensed milk no no no
no again condensed milk that's [ __ ]
okay we're talking about sugar here okay
dude we only offer we're like those
steakhouses uh-huh we're gonna throw you
out you asked for steak sauce i don't
think there'd be any regulation you're
allowed to wear a bikini it's just a
dress code it's fine
right but bikini too much too much
dude if you want to see the bikini you
got to get in the job
java boom boom room okay oh really oh
yeah other than that they're fully
clothed they're pretty as [ __ ]
really yeah
so you got an incentive to get into the
job earlier so i drink my coffee it's a
monthly fee i don't know if i have time
in the morning to go into the boom boom
room and drink my coffee i don't know
i'll tell you man it's not for you then
unless it was late night and you were
serving
booze in the coffee but now you got a
whole situation well then we gotta do
the alcohol license that's the whole
section what's going on with tiger thick
just hustling buddy yeah hustling
because it's a good whiskey the best yep
best it's good where can people get it
uh you get thickboy.com okay you can get
on there we have our uh
um
bourbon outfitters the one who supplied
online and then in texas it's in all the
main stores there's specs nice we're
yeah we're big in texas just got into
boston great
awesome one of my shows have it
there you go baby very good five star
review dog
it's very good yeah it's great i love it
i have it at home i served it the other
day everybody loved it
look at that dog oh i do i tell you how
to uh
i make an announcement now because it's
official i have to cancel my theater
show in chicago i heard
i heard not from you but i heard and i
correct me if i'm wrong that should that
theater
require proof of vaccination
even a a booster from what i was told a
positive test wasn't enough you have to
have a vaccination card and an updated
booster
and it's not the den theater's fault
it's my team's fault for not
reviewing the contract and just to say
okay we'll do it there because we we
needed a place in fast cause i the tough
mudder is there on saturday on the 27th
and then i want to do stamp on 26
because you know the rain team's there
tough mudder teams there some honored
people all my people are there so i want
to do a show friday night so they found
this with the quickness no one reviewed
the contract we didn't know to this week
we're getting all these emails and jay
was in monterey at the car show and
usually jay's on it and uh we just
didn't see it and i'm like i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
place and then jay's like dude look at
go to the website look at the covet
protocols now to be fair once i hit up
dan theater like let's see if we can get
out of it for your show most people
don't care now i'm like i care my
audience cares i'm not anti-vaxxed do
what you do whatever you feel
comfortable with but what i can't be
part of is if it's forced upon people
then i'm out especially in august of
2022 when we know the science now before
i get it everyone's scared you're doing
your thing
i guess that's the right thing do people
feel safe august summer 2022 what are we
doing here i've never even heard of it
no one assumed it either now to be fair
to the den theater they're like listen
we don't necessarily agree with it
either it's part of this theater overall
the theaters come together we don't have
the power they they have a coalition
yeah that's what they're saying so
they're like let's see if we can ask
them we can get out like it's too short
of notice i went love you guys i'll
definitely be back yeah but this i can't
be part of it it's hard so now i'm doing
uh a 30 minute spot on the 7 30 show at
laugh factory chicago okay 7 30 and
almost on the 9 30 show so i close the
shows out 7 30 9 30. good uh we'll have
the ticket links up but just go to laugh
actors chicago that's awesome the whole
team will be there yeah that's awesome
um what's up it's just i'm going to
canada i didn't i didn't think about it
yeah did would you like covered laws
right right now well but i'm strict i'm
going to canada for our boy tarek's
wedding
and um don't get me in canada though
right well his his ladies from ottawa oh
that makes sense so i'm fine i don't
know when you fly to ottawa
you're going to tell the canadian
government
everything about you well you know you
have to wear basket on the planet
correct you have to wear a mask on a
plane you have to show proof of
vaccination everything you're flying to
north korea yeah there's a lot it's very
very invasive it's very interesting
there's mandatory information you have
to tell the government and that's new
for canada well that's right true door
trudeau
is a i mean what are we talking about
here
biggest narcissist in the world yeah
his dad's fidel castro anyways but uh
the thing about that is is canada is a
nightmare because of the dictator and uh
that dude you know but it's all for
safety dude
sure
yeah yeah he wants he just doesn't want
to invade invade your privacy and make
sure he controls everything because
that's not what's going on in canada and
people are stoked about it up there oh
they love it they love it they're so
happy
what's funny about the world you go to a
rogan concert you just you're out in the
world it's so funny i mean a rogan show
i don't say concert
but what's funny is that like don't you
see such a massive difference between
what the news tells you the world's like
and what the world's really like don't
you all feel that way
uh repeat the last sentence like the
difference between what the news says
the world is about and where the
problems are and what the issues are
versus well marx says because he's on
the road with me so he sees actual
people that's i've always said that
about social whatever's going on social
media when trump was run for president
you know if we're in this bubble in l.a
you're like oh my god things there's no
way trump's going but then when you get
into texas you get into boise you get
into certain areas you're like
oh i actually he's probably remember i
think he's going to win trying
you're dealing that's what i'm saying
you're dealing with real interaction
with people so that's why my perspective
on social media
it might be one thing and you if you're
in that world and you you're on social
media all the time you're constantly
looking at it and take talking twitter
you're like oh my god the world's on
fire everyone hates each other and trump
there's no way trump can win or this
but i get to see it i mean every other
weekend when i'm on the road real people
meet hundreds and thousands of people
it's like oh none of that is
that this is so extreme you guys aren't
living in reality man none of that's
real my huge distortion is yes i want to
see i'm really waiting to see if
if this mar-a-lago raid turns out to be
nothing
if this mar-a-lago raid turns out to not
result in an indictment of the former
president i don't think we'll find out
well because it compromises fbi
yes but they have to ultimately give us
a reason
there's got to be well also is there an
indictment here when you do a search
warrant
and especially a high profile like this
one like this
it's got to yield fruit
and if it doesn't go it's a major
calculator
it's a miscalculation because now you've
lost
left right you've lost all trust in the
government which they did during the
pandemic
you've lost all trust with the russia
probe too ultra russiagate that is so
con you know
that's a little cloudy so i don't think
people are like i think people that are
in the know are like this is ridiculous
but in general people like all right
they didn't find anything there with
this now
and they have to actually vouch for it
otherwise if they decide to go it's too
confidential we can't release the
information okay
let me know how it goes for you you're
losing left and right
that's that's that's what the foundation
i think merit garland who's the district
attorney would have to resign
because if if that's what you're doing
and the fbi is going along with it even
it even makes the fbi look bad the
justice department looked bad so it's
like
this is a big [ __ ] risk
but what's the takeaway from all this
listen
the former president isn't safe from
this
nobody's safe
that's what's scary they do that to a
form say what you want about trump i get
it say whatever you want i don't give a
[ __ ] he
he's the former president of the united
states has a good chance of being your
next the next president too they can do
that to the president what do you think
is going to happen to you that has no
power no voice that's what's scary yeah
that's right did you guys see the part
about
the other side of this is
potentially that
trump was
harboring documents that would be uh you
know classified
well incriminating to the fbi as far as
something bad about russiagate that he
was like holding on to this as like that
would be
that was one of the narratives the
larger issue is if he had i don't think
i think that's was the idea was let me
get ahead of this and see what the [ __ ]
they have right right i don't know but
but the other issue is that if he had
documents
that are as secretive as they were
saying because there are certain
documents that the president possesses
that are so secretive so it would be
like the nuclear codes and stuff if
anybody had those you'd be in jail
that's a problem but but also that a lot
a lot like they had a former person who
was in i forget maybe bush's cabinet or
uh bill clinton's
was like including not a trump fan
because the way this works our
presidents can they can declassify
certain documents and take them with
them and he was just so people know how
this works he's like it's it's pretty
stupid than they've been put out there
if you think when
donald trump was leaving the white house
the the oval office if you think he was
grabbing documents opponent no he has a
staff that does it and they're not going
to be like oh let's make sure we put
this he's not one that's not documented
no no so it's a staff that put all the
documents and declassified them and also
before the president can leave one thing
that many presidents do is they
declassify certain documents
and they have to get approval so he took
the def classified documents which tons
of presidents have done but they're
trying to make it seem like oh he took
ones that weren't declassified and this
is complicated it wasn't reading it
doesn't secretly keep it doesn't work
like that yeah but also this same
general is like he also doesn't have
that power access so and they know that
that's what's strange about all this
like it's not like he's hiding the name
that's what i'm saying and the standard
the standard which it creates because
like okay now you're gonna have to prove
that right if you're going after them
you would have to prove they're not
getting things i see i don't think they
have to prove it but wait when you when
you issue a search warrant when you
issue a search warrant i mean to indict
to move further with the prosecutor
issue a search warrant
you especially one of this high profile
almost always you
you have done your homework as the feds
to say
this is going to result in some kind of
an indictment or where we are going
we're going to justify this warrant if
we justify it to a judge though right we
have a but we haven't used that judge we
have a problem i know we have a probable
we have probable cause and we have
evidence that says criminal behavior was
going on now the goal in my opinion and
i think it i think republicans and
democrats want him off the ticket i
think republicans want him off the
ticket because he's a mob boss and they
have to they have to they have to kiss
the ring every one of them every single
one of them and i think republicans and
democrats would have a very strong
interest in getting that guy to [ __ ] off
the ticket get him and die and they're
trying everything and they're trying
everything into this magnet yeah but
they want desantis republicans want a
guy like the sanders yes yeah yeah and
so do i yes anyway but the the problem
there is
what they don't realize and a lot of
people have said this they go trump was
kind of like in the middle he was maybe
going to throw his support for a
desantis or that dude in south carolina
or whatever he was but now that they did
this they've lit they've lit the fire
the crowd
oh i was gonna be cool
now that you've embarrassed me well now
the only reason i'm running is because i
have deep hatred and vengeance yeah and
now not only am i going to run and win
because who's going to beat him who's
going to beat him go i'd love to hear
about kamala harris dude yeah because
everyone loves her the most disliked
vice president ready of all time
now hold on so you're going to have her
as your main front runner and pete
budakitch who i think is brilliant
he's not a leader
no no no no no no no no america
he was a transportation public but you
know so you're gonna have those two take
on trump and trump was gonna be cool but
you morons
you've riled up the [ __ ] beast talked
about the comb over your pokemon this
bear has a comb over and he has and he's
a horrible spray tan and bat nuts under
his eyes you fired that [ __ ] eagle
maniac up and man did you [ __ ] up
because you know now he's coming you
know what he lives and his only goal is
to ruin you guys his
united states his favorite thing is
revenge
his favorite thing and it's not good as
a president it's not good because he
doesn't care about the you know all this
[ __ ] he his sole purpose now for the
next four years
is to ruin you guys and he's going to
open up on these fbi rates on you and
then it's this tick to protect game and
it's a disaster for all of us oh my god
how do you guys not oversee this i agree
you guys are supposed to be brilliant
you [ __ ] morons you're dealing with
the guy who prides himself of vengeance
i think it's actually a i think not to
be a conspiracy theorist i think it's a
republican slash democrat plot i think
they're they're all in on it they're all
like get this [ __ ] gold
because now you fired him up man and now
he has a purpose
he he's like man that white that
president gets terrible but he's like
yeah it's terrible i will eat all the
crow just to make sure that i come back
and do the exact same thing to them you
[ __ ] months know what game you're
playing dude yeah there's nothing that
guy wants more than to get back at you
now that's right and it's not good for
left it's not good for the right it's
not good for any of us he's gonna come
with [ __ ] furious anger and vengeance
yeah
and it's gonna be fun to watch but
america's gonna be on fire
it's so interesting the border beach
closed though so the what the world will
be lost yeah the border will be closed
and it interesting though yeah you
[ __ ] how do you guess not i know this
i'm an idiot i know that's what i mean i
know this that like i don't follow
politics i'm i'm looking at it going i
wouldn't do this why are you guys famous
i mean unless there's real criminals you
guys have political poly degrees from
harvard yeah i want to see i really want
to see what what's going on i want to
see what the [ __ ] is really going on
with these uh these things
with it with this affidavit and here's
my other thing hold on hold on
let me get this straight you're gonna
you're gonna raid a former president's
house but you're not gonna raid hunter
biden's house like do both of them if
you're gonna do it do both of them so at
least the america's like that makes
sense
you don't want a double silence you
don't want a double standard no no but
if anything you should have raided 100
biden's house first this guy's a insane
liability we know he's in collusion with
russian trump we know for a fact yeah
his laptop he's throwing dick pics out
and doing meth like we can't have this
yeah like right here i think the biggest
thing was that they [ __ ] basically
said
uh something to the effect of
all those intelligence figures came out
and said there's nothing to see here
when it came to the hunter laptop and
that was before the election that's a
problem that's problem
but there are a lot of people that that
hate trump that much who think he's that
much of a danger i get it and they're
conservatives there are a lot of
conservatives
who like my own dad
don't talk to him about trump he can't
stand the [ __ ] guy my dad's a
republican he's a he's basically a
pro-choice republican but he's [ __ ]
conservative he's a libertarian but he
he he'll give you a thousand reasons why
trump is the enemy but so so anyway blah
blah blah all right
my man have they they've made a mess
made a mess you riled up the [ __ ] guy
that all he cares about is getting back
and he's gonna he's gonna uncover every
rock on this [ __ ] continent yeah to
make sure he gets his vengeance correct
you've you guys royally if you actually
hate him you should have done the exact
opposite feed his ego like yeah we're
good thank you so much for all your help
yeah you kill him with kindness and
you're like all right my work here is
done my work
bend the knee
until 2024 and get somebody else in
there but you didn't do that
god they [ __ ] up and it's from from
the side it's fun to watch
because i like chaos okay as do i yeah
i'm living in hollywood going protest
i'm not down there okay
i get my knife and forks out
[Music]
um finished it finished editing my
special last night finally got a bad
feeling yeah
it feels good doing a cover art it's a
it's a a
sigh of relief yeah it's a side relief
but then anxiety picks up when you let
when you drop it yeah it's back up i got
to drop it and i'll drop it soon but
then i also want to do i'm already
writing my next i'm gonna i'm gonna
release a half hour next time i'm gonna
do a house how long is this one uh 45
minutes that's fine yeah you have clips
and stuff oh and i told you i i wouldn't
i'm gonna say that we can release it on
thursday okay next thursday yeah i think
is that september 1st i think it is yeah
yeah i'd really say september 1st all
right
um because you and i will be in austin
september 3rd
doing things
don't worry about it hey let's do some
current events but um let's make sure i
was listening to our show i don't know
if i told you this
and we don't describe what people are
seeing
i didn't like listening to it so now
we're going to describe what the [ __ ] is
on the screen
because most people are listening to
this podcast so we apologize for that i
didn't like that section we tried before
but i know i was like this is not fun
listening right now because we're just
talking about you know what we're doing
we're going oh neat cool haha we assume
they're watching i mean that's like this
thing yeah it's a visual show so anyway
we'll describe chen you describe it all
right this is a couple at a oakland a's
game and they're being oh they're being
sought after by the police because they
did a sexual act here on the very top of
the bleachers and someone filmed it i'll
show you real quick
so what we're watching is uh it's an
oakland haze game and there's it's a
slow game and there's nobody in there
there's nobody
they're in the top stands and there's a
girl and with her boyfriend maybe they
just met and they're both a's fans
they're big mark mcguire fans back in
the day they're the bash brother fans
and what she's doing is she decided to
go she went i want a hot dog in my mouth
and went well the line so far and looks
long i have a flashlight you can't eat
it and she went you can't you can't bite
it but you can suck on it
that sounds delicious yeah and there's
gonna be no mustard on it so she's she's
scarfing down in this video a flesh hot
dog does it look like flesh hands a
flesh glizzy does she does it look like
her hands are behind her back there like
she's under arrest no not at all it
looks like she looks like her hands are
on that pipe son
okay
i had a she's scarfing down the glizzy
kids i had a girl one time hopefully
that helps the audible listeners i had a
girl one time
do go down and do that and she put her
hands behind her back like she was under
arrest oh well that was a bad thing i
was like it'd be a red flag right now i
was like your boyfriend did some stuff
out here i was like yeah but that looks
like uh that looks like her hands are
behind her back can't tell so far her
hands are on that glizzy boy that's a
bad that's a ufo picture it's so blurry
that's [ __ ] ufo quality [ __ ] but also
at those games i mean yeah dude there's
cameras everywhere what are you thinking
i mean we know you're in the they're and
when i say they're in the the 25 rock
pile seats they sure are but that's the
i'm in the rock pile and that boy is
rock hard the point is and he's just
looking off
he's enjoying the game he's like this
nothing to see here is that a bird it's
bottom of this [ __ ] six and who gives
a [ __ ] they played 9 000 they're
protesting that the a's are losing i'm
gonna suck his dick
yeah anyway congratulations but they got
arrested no they're trying to find them
i'm sure we can't even see what they
look like grainy video that could be any
that might that might be bigfoot i
guarantee every cop who any cop who gets
that as a file they're like can you put
that at the very bottom can you put that
in my drawer that i'm never going to
because we don't
hey you were you blowing this guy yeah
let us take all our resources in oakland
california who doesn't have enough
issues oh my god and figure out who this
guy's getting his dick sucked at the a's
game
correct all right so anthony fauci he
will be leaving his position this
december
somebody said something about so we're
looking at a picture of fouchy here yeah
and he's 90 years old yes and he is uh
he is now
retiring somebody said something about
do something else somebody said
something interesting yeah valjee for 50
years
because of the positions he was in has
had people kissing his ass for money
coming up to him and kissing his ass for
money for literally 40 years
at least 30 i mean
yeah he was a runner he never stopped he
runs every day
and they said with a massive tiny little
guy who runs
yes and they said
he's he's it's hard for it not to go to
your head when people are coming in
kissing your ring and begging for money
and you're in the power to do it
so that that was an interesting idea so
what's the point there the point is that
if he seems a little arrogant it might
be the job
i never got arrogance i got a guy who
was overly cautious
and and and uh believed in what he was
doing i i don't agree i think it was way
it was overkill but he was he seemed
very overly cautious a lot of people
thought he was like this that again when
you refer yourself into third person
pretty irrigated oh i never saw him yeah
he's like listen anthony fauci yeah oh i
i do think he's arrogant i do think that
it's it's
made a ton of mistakes the power went to
his head and on for you know he's had
this historic career unfortunately i
think now he's more known for mistakes
than anything
but
maybe that's just the algorithm i'm
getting on my newsfeed yeah ain't that
the truth who the [ __ ] knows that guy's
gonna have to have security for the rest
of his life yeah
yeah tough gig what is this all right so
this is a girl went missing about two
weeks ago and it was at a campsite in
tahoe somewhere so the police tried for
two weeks trying to find this girl any
kind of like in the water though yeah in
the water like everywhere they had sonar
all that stuff so they weren't able to
find it but then this youtube youtuber
youtubing two youtubers thank you very
much yes two youtubers same youtube
channel they're professional divers they
did it within 48 hours they found her
they found it yeah
what is what happened she did she they
still don't know exactly but it seems
like she just she made the wrong turn
went into a ramp and went into the water
and flipped
oh man yeah she was i think 16 years old
jesus christ [ __ ] dude those youtubers
though you know the the
the actual like officials are probably
pretty embarrassed too they are
youtubers or like founder
that's what they're saying how they do
it they're they're they're because they
with video and stuff where they can
locate exactly where you are yeah they
all talk to each other and they figure
out the coordinates where the sun is all
that have you seen that there was
another thing where they found they did
the same thing but for this one they did
uh because you know like boats have
sonars that they said they had the same
type of equipment the police had but
they're just they knew how to manipulate
the system to where they could find it
better they also probably know that lake
you know they're professional divers
yeah they're it's what they specialize
in yeah
they found like a bunch of people too
some [ __ ] on that oh they found more
than one yeah they they're known for
finding
cases like 20 years old my boy uh my boy
um a.g who owns toehold that with my
partner how many people in touhou forgot
just me andy stumpf yeah
ownership no no he's the founder okay
and he's a professional diver he's he's
a serious diver and he was diving in uh
[ __ ] um
lake mead you know that where all those
bodies were washing up like the mafia
bodies like they were in drums and he
was diving and he
they saw a brand new tahoe like a brand
new
new the papers in it never hello and he
was like either somebody was killed or
they they [ __ ] put it in there as an
insurance scam sure and then they pulled
it up they actually i think they pulled
it out it was brand new and which is a
beast to do and it ended up being like
it literally ended up being
not a mystery it ended up being like
apparently it rolled
into the water and fell in like fell off
a cliff or something because they didn't
put it in
this brand new [ __ ] tahoe that nobody
reported they were like oops nothing to
see here well insurance yeah
no what they think is what they think
please lie is that the person no no no
tell me someone was married no what they
think was that they at first they
thought it was a murder yeah but then
they that what they think happened was
the campers had their truck there
the truck rolled without them knowing
and they thought it got stolen yeah
instead it rolled off the [ __ ] cliff
and went into the water or some [ __ ] so
i'll get their whole story maybe i'm
making all that out but the point is
that they saw that
okay this is a crazy video make sure you
get the details then don't call me
please
yeah i know it's just random it's just
in
there you're saying jimmy hoffman
although he he's no no he so they hire
him to go find bobbies yeah he's pulled
out a lot of where the [ __ ] was he on
this one yeah i know that's why i was
thinking about it but they've hired him
he that's one of the things you do what
else you got jen all right this is in
ithaca new york this woman was outside
on the phone on her cell phone and then
this crazy fox with rabies attacked her
oh
i don't think there's audio oh so rabies
make these uh actually yeah they make
them crazy so you see this here
she's older but i feel like i could pick
him up this is the last thing you expect
yeah this is the last just brazen
so she kicks it away he keeps coming
back
and now it's on her hand too oh and he
keeps coming back she kicks it she's
fighting she's having a good fight
the last thing you think whatever still
going to kill you oh he was the [ __ ]
wolf oh my god and it grabs her hand
again this is
oh
he's
they can do whatever they want with
their mouths
dude just spike him on the [ __ ]
that's a neighbor coming out to help
neighbors it's so crazy just kept very
good for the viewer for the audible
listen the the listeners the the
neighbors in insane shape okay comes out
there
an adonis no so a fox just keeps
attacking this woman yeah and she's
kicking it she's an old man not really
getting a picture of her hand
and now we're looking at a picture of
her hand oh yeah not bad no but that's
a lot worse didn't it no video looked a
lot worse hey
not bad i thought it was gonna be like
totally gone for the uh audio listeners
a few scratches yeah but you know what
that hurts like a [ __ ] the fox
comes up bites you and holds on to your
calf bites you again on the calf just
bites your hand it holds onto your hand
it's just what you want to do is hold it
down with your hand down and kneel on it
and squash its [ __ ] head
i that's how you do it yeah look you
look look yeah we are you gotta kneel on
his neck fox fox look you [ __ ]
don't pull away just go here
me
no no this is what i would do no yep
ground pound right all that effort and
you're small and frail yeah you're like
fouchy right so yeah yeah i'm not
fagging so i'm ted cruz right so i take
this he's ted cruz yeah i'm taking he's
big he's big and brilliant so i would my
hands like this i'm like oh my god this
is terrible that's a [ __ ] that's a fox
don't care that would kill him i don't
know because he's holding on to your
hand and then what i do okay so he rips
your hand after i i don't give a [ __ ] he
ain't letting go few scratches that way
you lose you lose a lot of so he's like
this right i ground by the tail and i
just slowly stretch him out really yep
until i rip his [ __ ] tail off but
he's holding on your hand don't care
dude though you're shooting the fixture
no it's not a crocodile it's a stupid
[ __ ] you know what fox is what it's a
cat basically it's a cat dog hold on
it's cat dog it's cat dog cat and
they're stupid you've ever been bit by a
cat hold on it does nothing yeah they're
stupid
do we lose a house cat they're stupid
they bite you're like what are you doing
there's a netflix there's a whole
netflix show on cats guess who didn't
watch it this guy well have you seen the
documentary don't [ __ ] with cats yes
that's that's very different that is so
dark it's so dark i can't take it it's
so good
though are we going to say
oh no i was just saying don't talk [ __ ]
about cats oh like
mock outrage man rabies so rapies makes
these boys wild yeah rabies trying to
kill them rabies makes these
this video i think we saw it before but
this is a bobcat that also had rabies
god now bobcat we got problems now we
got problems claws they say rabies is
the bath salts of the animal world yeah
it is
where's the those if you have rabies
check it out if you have rabies you will
you will [ __ ] uh basically you don't
know uh go crazy near water it makes you
afraid of water isn't that weird who
says that interesting so that's the fact
that's caught you have water phobia and
you will freak out see about this
podcast
bobcat's a problem
i would be screaming like this you just
remember this one
that's what he did your technique
running kind of no no he
shot put it you gotta slam it he's got a
gun there too oh shoot that [ __ ] it's
gonna be tough to shoot him though
unless you hold him in schumann's
stomach
hey look neck
did i show you the video of my buddy
fighting a raccoon in his own house and
he shoots it
did i show you that was it a rabbit
record
the raccoon was in his house his dog's
going crazy and my body's biting it he
finally shoots it right in his own
living room did you see that no oh dude
see that see that's the content i'm in
for so your buddy diving into the the
lake and finding a new chevy not fun
right your buddy grabbing a raccoon
shooting him fun yeah right that's true
that was boring wasn't it apologize
horrible
hold on oh let me see dave portnoy and
[ __ ] jason whitlock they go at it oh
[ __ ] i feel like they're on the same
team
depending what is
uh so right now we're looking at a tweet
it says dude fortnite l president is the
fraud oh so this is jason whitlock
saying this this is jason whitlock's
tweet correct he put dave pornoy el
presidente is a fraud he has no
redeeming qualities other than his
wealth remove his money he wouldn't have
a friend in this world if we weren't
living in an era completely hostile to
masculinity poorni would be broke in
boston delivering pizza
okay and then what's jason and why do
you go after
el presidente
is a fraud so that's just basically what
he said so this but also whitlock is
kind of like like he likes the drama
that's what they do
so then day just played funny because
he
that's a 10-8 round for portnoy
that's a 10-8 round
the wind out of my [ __ ]
you know i'm i'm getting a lot of dumb
responses but this might be the dumbest
do you think i'm chasing the approval of
knockoff portnoy you ain't that stupid
are you my actions speak pretty loud
huh you're a far bigger sellout than
portland a guy who built a toxic frat
boy culture of sexual harassment at
barcelona wait hold on an incredible
disappointment and your formerly
incredible talent has just been
completely wasted it's sad huh hold on
so
but he goes you're you're looking uh he
goes you're looking for approval of uh
clay travis and goes uh you think i'm
chasing an approval of a knockoff of
portnoy i didn't know jason so jaden
jason whitlock and just for listeners
jason whitlock and uh
and clay travis used to be partners wow
they used to be have a show together i
like clay traps a lot and i i know i
know jason whitlock i've met him a
couple times and and he's he seems like
a great guy he's you a smart guy i mean
some of his takes are terrible i like
him
why i don't know but it's weird he went
bad on clay travis there too he was a
knockoff of portnoy i'm trying to get
that approval it's like oh wow there's
issues with wait let me go back to that
let me see what that what he actually
meant still chasing the approval of oh
no because
no because jimmy lemke said this
he said
no no no no jimmy lemke tweeted to
jason woodlock still chasing the
approval of clay travis eh you're a far
bigger sellout than portnoy a guy who
built a toxic frat
boy culture of sexual harassment at
barstool you're an incredible
disappointment and your formerly
incredible talent's just been wasted
completely wasted now he goes i mean a
lot of dumb responses you think i'm
chasing approval of a knockoff of
portnoy
oh oh
whoa
of a knockoff of portland meaning clay
travis yeah that's weird so it's a
little shady i don't get that i don't i
don't
get this they used to have a business on
that outkick coverage and he used to be
on there all the time apparently he's on
his own but i don't get this as men i
don't get when men do this to each other
i don't get it [ __ ] it yeah i don't get
it clout chasing
dramas yeah i don't get it you're too
old everybody's totally travis like i'm
sorry if i'm jason whitlock like he's
never been mentioned on this show so you
go after portnoy go after clay travis
like getting get headlines
people that do that like that whole
dramatic thing and beast thing create
drama
they don't have any other talent like
they've run out of ways to get ratings
and so it's a way to make sure you're
getting likes and clicks and i can't
entertain it i like it to be honest
sometimes like i wish i was more like
that i can't do it yeah it doesn't make
sense who is jason whitlock
he he's a he's a good question he he
well he was a com he's he was on he was
on fox for a long time he was on fox
sports he knows sports really well he's
uh you'll see him on fox it's kind of a
conservative
yeah he's very smart when it comes to
sports and like and and he usually has
some good takes on like lebron and kevin
durant stuff like that
he was a uh
he was a source for on out kick he was
he was you know he's good on there i
don't know what's going on i won a
national journalism award let me see uh
in june jason willock officially
partnered alongside trey clay travis uh
outkick
and then uh wow just a year later he
announced whitlock's departure would
like to maintain response to his tweet
do not believe anything written or said
about me unless i say it all else is
fake news month later he gave an
interview to front office sports when
she said uh it was a bad business deal a
byproduct of my failure to properly vet
my business partners wow so yeah he had
an issue
i don't know
when you see guys coming after portnoy
like that
and there's not really any specific
accusation it's just like what you've
done is bad
see my my thing about that is there are
so many other people to go bad on
over other than dave portland yeah but
you're not going to get clicks yeah
you're not going to get featured on
youtube because it's like a name yeah
what do you name a masculine thing that
is not actually masculine right he's
presenting like he does pizza reviews
and he started bar still sports which
provides a lot of entertainment yeah
like what is it that you don't like yeah
i don't know oh he's a frat boy okay
smart boy yeah you know many frat boys
in this world he's going to be worth
about 800 million dollars yeah he put
that all together and why why are you
upset yeah
he created a service people wanted to
buy you know he created a community and
there's only the only reason why
whitlock has portnoy's name in his mouth
because porno is successful you're not
going after someone who's not successful
no support no i didn't go after him yeah
but also let's just say this barstool
sports didn't become popular because
it's it's chauvinistic and it became
popular because it's funny because dudes
were able to laugh about [ __ ] on it and
a lot of the stuff was legitimately
funny you know what i'm saying so also
it had these girls on there i mean like
of course
but also like entertaining girls too
he's just going beautiful women and and
comedy yeah
okay
yeah
yeah some of it might have been
uh chauvinistic some of it might have
been misogynistic you know you don't all
right
watch it right you know it's not like on
mainstream tv but also some of those
like the girls doing it's like yeah it's
edgy girl stuff too they're talking
about blown dudes do you know how many
comedians how many comedians how many
female comedians talk about their vagina
and and [ __ ] dudes right i mean
there's also poor toxic also launched
caller daddy which is literally the
biggest female show in the world thank
you that was all his doing thank you
yeah it undermines the argument you know
that it's like chauvinistic or something
it's just something that doesn't make
sense i mean listen there's a reason
they're coming after him he's very
successful
you're not coming after guys not doing
anything he's just fine that's so funny
you're fat oh god
this is a great commercial i haven't
seen it so this is a commercial in
russian
okay in russia guys in bed with a girl
is there all doing this or not guys in
bed with a girl doesn't matter i'll
explain he's in bed with a girl
she's like
she's watching him get rested he's it's
in the morning time he's going to leave
he's putting his shirt on she goes
what's your name anyway and he just
looks at her he doesn't answer he says
would you like to stay for breakfast
and he still doesn't say anything all of
a sudden he gets into a wheelchair you
see him in a wheelchair he just finished
having sex now there's a guy at the door
it's his her husband he's standing there
with his bags he drops his bag
this little guy looks at him in in the
wheelchair pat's the husband on on their
arm
and then
you see the husband you see the girl
kind of shrug her shoulder she just got
caught cheating
and this guy goes what if i took your
place in the wheelchair he looks at the
camera
and basically says do not park and
disable
[Laughter]
what if i took your place yeah
he said he was having sex and he goes
don't bark and disabled and handicapped
oh we're like never thought about that
that's a flower that's a that's a
russian ad pretty funny that is funny
all right
marcus my
sentence to life
abusing his stepson jesus christ florida
man who was nabbed for horrifically
abusing his stepson thanks to a
fast-acting waitress has been sentenced
to life in prison
uh timothy lee wilson was found guilty
of false imprisonment aggravated child
abuse in child neglect in june um when a
server at a mrs potato restaurant in
orlando noticed that he didn't order the
boy food on new year's day and that
child was covered with scratches so
carvalho quickly wrote a note reading do
you need help and flashed it to the then
11 year old victim while standing behind
his oblivious parents
we see that note there do you need help
with an okay if we see the picture the
guy who did it man i would have been
suspicious just based on his watch what
happened to him in jail you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i got an 11 year old i [ __ ] cut that
guy's head off
the boy nodded at the police jesus
christ that poor boy i'm super concerned
and i don't know what to do can you give
me some advice carvalho asked a
dispatcher investigator
investigation found that the child had
been subjected to torture and neglect by
wilson and his mother
it's always great when people take
action you hear a lot of stories like
this hey scumbag that's you know
childhood pieces of [ __ ] man
god that poor kid man that's the
waitress shout out to that [ __ ]
weakness god bless that one otherwise
that kid is living a life of [ __ ]
hell man
flaviana carvalho wow if you want a
little goddamn superhero god damn it
jesus christ give us hey man
my boy is stallone he's files
and he and he had her he had her face on
his arm and he got the dog from rocky
tattooed over it damn he loved her man
he loved her
25 years
former model 50 she's before she's a
great woman gorgeous daughters yeah that
family i love their daughters that
family is such a great family
25-year marriage
[ __ ]
yeah she filed
she's 54 she looks incredible she's
amazing keeps going down tim yeah
she's also a class i grew up on a farm
keep scrolling down jen so you can see
the tattoo oh the tattoo uh yeah
oof yeah you gotta cover it up
[ __ ] dude
yeah it's tough at his age
oh look at these youngsters god he was
he looked straight from tango and cash
in that yeah
[ __ ] man that bums me out ah i'm all
right yeah he just used to wait did you
guys see that he's he's his daughters
are doing a podcast in the old you're
doing fine yeah
yeah i love his daughters yes that's
right yeah i get we they do our exact
studio they're like do you want to take
it down like no who's coming in like
stone sisters like let me have all of it
i didn't take it i left everything
let's go to happier ones here
okay
i don't know which one
uh olivia well i guess jason siddique
has served
her papers
wow well she was dating she was on stage
and so this is just her commentary on it
that it was you know calculated and
vindictive and petty and uh it was very
upsetting to her but ultimately
that impacted everyone around her you
know and
uh she can deal with that but
why do you got to bring everyone else
into it right i agree with that man kids
are eight and five yeah it's tough
wow
did you guys see her movie which one um
i believe it's called book smart oh yeah
with the two kids yeah i tried watching
them playing out for me really too i
really enjoyed i'm too old
so here's a little you know i know we
love sharks on this show so the scuba
diver gives it
wow prevent a shark attack when a
shark's coming towards you you'd
actually want to do is not splash turn
around face the animal and maintain eye
contact you want to act like a predator
she says you can place your hand on the
top of their head push down gently and
that will redirect them away from you
i'm not buying this at all so in the
video yeah you see her
stop turn around and the shark does stop
swimming towards her because i guess
it's you know it tricks the
shark into thinking oh this is some sort
of confrontation i'm not a prey that's
running away from me but she puts her
hand right on the shark's
nose and can kind of push it in a
different direction
too or
you would assume it does not work with
grey whites and there's a video of a guy
trying to put a great white and tonic
and it didn't work out
when i was in when i was in bora bora
there was a whole thing where they were
talking about how
i'm in bora bora and they say all there
are blacktip sharks problem was that a
great white i mean i'm sorry a tiger
shark a huge tiger shark found its way
in
to the bay to eat the black tips and it
was right it was literally right out i
didn't see it but it was right outside
our hotel that's a problem yeah right
outside yeah are black tips and i and
the reason i know that is i talked to
the guy who was on the jet ski and he
was driving around
and i was like why is he driving around
what the [ __ ] is going on
and i
my i didn't but
somebody who was we were there with said
oh i i talked to the guy because it made
no sense he's trying to scare them no
they're
so they they patrol that area to make
sure when the tiger shark is there uh
ruining that
yeah
so they keep it real hush-hush real
hush-hush like tiger sharks
then i talked to the oceanographer there
and they were like yeah it's very rare
and also they're not gonna bite you
around here so that's not true though
yeah no they're just trying to kill they
do oh no
so right there right in there right
among those huts there there was a giant
pretty easy to see too oh you see them
you see everything yeah you see
everything i love it ah don't worry
about it man okay right there and we
were all swimming you swim right off
your hotel
is there bathrooms in there bro yeah
yeah you should in the water oh no this
goes in the water oh those hotel no
those hotel those those cabins
are first class look inside of them
they're as nice as any suite you'll ever
be in any suite interesting they're sick
no that's the four seasons that's the
best hotel there's yeah there's
bathrooms you have tubs jacuzzis in
there it's i mean it's [ __ ] oh wow
the best most comfortable king size beds
i mean it's unbelievable
couch kitchen everything oh yeah yeah
don't let the thatcher doesn't look
surprised don't let that surprise you
there's gord that that place is
unbelievable
all right marcus the last one i had here
uh it shows a
it's one of these cases where you go
protect yourself at all times this guy's
in the box room and it's called the
sucker punch but
they're saying he touched gloves as a
distraction to then hit the guy but
technically they're in the fight the
referee had okayed them to go back and
then there's some other examples of
other
kinds of sucker punches so he just just
knocked down they touch gloves he
immediately hits him
and he just falls straight back it's
poor sportsmanship i mean it's
definitely not acceptable in mma or
boxing boom boom yeah yeah he know what
he's doing yeah that's a sucker punch
and they're saying in comparison
remember when floyd mayweather did a
version of that
to uh yes uh they're saying he didn't
floyd didn't initiate the glove touch
the other guy did yeah right if you want
to do that i'm gonna hit you yeah this
guy initially no yeah yeah that's not
cool
i'm sure that i can do anything he
doesn't get fined for that or anything i
don't think so what are you gonna do
it's a lot it's the clock was running
what are you gonna do i mean yeah that
guy's a piece of [ __ ] man what a that
[ __ ] he's like i just wanna show you how
quickly those [ __ ] knock you
out to a boxer like that right well yeah
it's a wide-open shot victor ortiz was a
guy yeah
yep
yeah man but damn that's that's
dangerous too huh [ __ ] yeah boxing yeah
what a dick yeah i mean just that's
never okay
well there's gonna be no uh sucker
punches in appleton wisconsin uh friday
i will be doing uh two sets at the laugh
factor in chicago get your tickets now
that [ __ ] will sell out um so you have
one show at 7 30 once you're at 9 30 and
then it's just there's other comics on
the lineup but i'm just closing the
shows out with 30 minutes of stand up so
that's one show at 7 31 show at 9 30 at
the laugh factor in chicago go to laugh
factory uh chicago for tickets tough
mudder is this saturday august 27th uh
tough mudder 11 a.m heat the thick
mudder use code team brendon for 10 off
all things uh la hollywood shop and
friends is august 31st that's a
wednesday i think it's at 8 o'clock show
hollywood improv shop and friends
special guest and then uh back on the
real tour appleton wisconsin september
8th through the 10th ontario california
ontario improv september 15th 17th i end
september in boston laugh boston
september 29th through october 1st thick
boy merch drops friday at 9 00 a.m
authentic
nba style thick boy jersey thick boy
shorts and we have these dope uh thick
boy hats dropping as well that's at 9am
thickboy.com get you some man where you
can be listen buddy i'll be in raleigh
north carolina good night september 8th
9th and 10th then i'll be in san jose
california improv september 15 16 17.
specan washington spokane comedy club
september 22-24
uh best of dropping the
um
dropping the austin episode tomorrow
look for best of i'm excited and uh i'll
be dropping my podcast the brian callan
show very soon i even sang
the intro music to it so get ready for
that [ __ ] kids all right we'll see you
soon all right kids love you let's find
kid we're out